hi guys Alyssa be crazy i'm ryan right
right right right now on you all know
love so very much what's up what's up
we're doing something a little bit
different today yeah this is a shout-out
video cuz we are so appreciative of all
you folks that we want to sing you
pretty songs are you ready uh yeah
almost what I'm gonna do real fast
Alyssa cuz I'm gonna change in some
pajama so I feel more comfortable for
this do it I'm gonna face style I don't
want to feel fat as I just ate
McDonald's yeah Jesus mud yeah [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you Marie coming to my home you
tell me how to [ __ ] you make my own food
how to spend my money you dress like a
goddamn slob you might would be a shame
to see you like this I swear to god
Murray I swear to god you open it up one
more time I'm gonna give you the man I
think you ever got a phone in your
goddamn John lozada you bring a couple
of girls over you live it's just what I
live with I got a minim I was gonna play
this one cool this video I'm extremely
nervous right now you know the thing
that he doesn't really let on is that
he's an amazing freestyle rapper he can
do it like not not even a joke either
like he's actually really good so it's
talent you know she go on America's Got
Talent yeah I'm really not that good now
yeah we've never seen this has never
been practiced rehearsed this have you
just SAT up on the couch and we're just
gonna say new songs we just as of the
second decide so i have to first find
some shoutouts and so we're just gonna
scroll through comments and we're gonna
get this shadow i'm gonna go back to the
last comment that i haven't done sorry
guys i'm really behind on commons blood
for Morrison you want to please don't
hurt me i went from Senor to like a
Russian Transylvanian kind of accent is
it the same thing dude I don't know if I
can do this I'm gonna try yeah I don't
know if I getting this eyelid I'm a
little high Oh
I didn't mean a rhyme on that one was
just so natural Murray South Pole 100 he
said I love you shout out please here we
go you know what let's get some music
yeah it's so straight up gangsta [ __ ]
right there dog didn't his name be South
Pole he makes me feel a new hole he
wants to come up here well that's the
story I've been told he feels so bold
you want to say [ __ ] like I love you
well I love you too and you know what i
want to do to you when i think of you
you want a shadow well how about this
shout out i'm wrapping a song for you
100 does he actually live in the South
Pole I don't know he doesn't know thou
for 100 there you can't do a whole
[ __ ] wraps okay I went pretty good
yeah better that be before either just
royalty free youtube remember that
remember that says right there classic
New York rappy one number royalty-free
be alright Philip t he said something
interesting said ryan look at my
comments on the into the storm reactions
done by Jerry don't even need a shout
out man but I need the mko reaction it's
gonna be epic well buddy that's uploaded
now and you know what when someone says
they don't you shout out that's some
humble [ __ ] right there dude so you know
what dude you can get a show now you
ready Alyssa I'm ready new beats Andy
what are we good whatever you want there
we go what's your name again Phillip
t-bill of tea
soon there be music I feel it coming
pretty sandwich not just a siren the
siren no it's called siren Murray oh
[ __ ] yeah this is that kind of wrapping
I like og filled up t comes up here and
he makes me want to feel so free I say
oh gee fill of tea you the OG homie you
want to talk to me guess what buddy this
is gonna be your shadow cuz your ass is
humble you want to come up here and your
comments you don't stumble I want to do
something she likes the bee bumble from
Transformers wouldn't you know that she
likes I kind of Michael they [ __ ] but
she loves to hear my lyrics when i spit
and I think about Philip and how he has
a cool thumbnail man that [ __ ] he never
fails to deliver i'm doing i get a
shiver when i quiver and i think about
Philip as I'm getting nearer Phil if we
like that you watch our videos yeah you
commented on Maleficent movie review yay
love you and guess what we don't need
you to tell us that you need it's okay
that was pretty good rhythm and ya know
we survived that round survivor we go on
to the next round it's gonna be the
shadow those going last word I made it
the last word oh we got another one
spaghetti he said shut up for me please
whenever you have the time well [ __ ]
dude seriously I've making time right
now okay appreciate it I'm a busy
[ __ ] guy I know others 11 as well
yeah a lot of other people do want one
but guess what man your third on this
list so wow we're gonna do this we're
gonna do this I'm nervous me too I'm
really cool i feel like i got really
here we go get ready spaghetti you're
gonna hear a new run coming for you I'm
gonna tell you about the thoughts I get
through when i think about you spaghetti
spaghetti are you ready you're better
stay steady cuz guess what man i'm gonna
come at you with another run here we go
you said whenever you have the time you
want one you want to shout out well how
about this shot out and here we go a
little cub scout you want to do
something you're a little stout don't
know what that means but I guess what
I'm rhyming it with it it doesn't matter
what it means I'm just gonna say
something that comes up these lyrics and
you know what I'm going green running
out of words to say oh [ __ ] i pray that
i can find another lyric here we go here
we go sogeti you deserve a good one man
you're the good man do you want to do
something man you're never rude you
always want to compliment me you make me
feel like Ryan wrestle happy you know a
man that could have been better [ __ ]
that one of them flex I wanna okay
spaghetti we're gonna take two real fast
mmm it's called come back time let's go
come back time when I think about
spaghetti I think about how I'm just
gonna get ready I think about spaghetti
and I want to know what's gonna happen
and sometimes I eat spaghetti and I feel
a little bit heavy get some meatball
sauce on that [ __ ] pasta sauce you
want to do something man well here we go
e string got put cheese on that and you
know what man had all the other crap i
want to taste that [ __ ] up I want to say
what's up when I see the spaghetti I
want to eat it out of a cup it doesn't
matter where I get it from just give me
a fork I don't care what's on I put on
some pork you want to do something man
well spaghetti you got a cool name dude
remain dude keep them well enough to you
cuz you're doing to give one man dude
ever be [ __ ] rude cuz you know what
man and you're like my joke so sometimes
they're a little bit too crude what I
want to do something do don't want to
think about it whenever you ask for a
shout out here we go here we go Alyssa
bus that blow [ __ ] Eddie you're pretty
honest you're pretty awesome you're
pretty humble spaghetti's you're free ah
dang I think that what's the word Oh
spaghetti's wait wait wait I long day
what you know what that's the freakin
words I get lost in a word and I can't
this would be really good if I was a
mind reader right now spaghetti ass for
a comment twice this guy is so [ __ ]
nice i look at it twice but maybe it's
gonna go turn into number thrice there's
not even music playing in the background
anymore oh [ __ ] what do i do call maria
[ __ ] I don't know it just fit it just
fit it rhyme